I didn't know you can get mad at kids
the poor you wanna fight you can wanna
fight the kid man kids are [ __ ] like
my daughter is an [ __ ] she a that we
are you made my daughter ha ru she can't
even talk she know a couple words right
she put a couple sentences together but
it's like every time I tell her
something she always got something say
back it don't matter what I say Shelby's
got to give me something back and make
me mad
we got the argument over juice the other
day she came into the room she's like
Daddy juice said no you had enough juice
go get some water and she looked at me
she's like can I get the goddamn I was
so mad I was very because I knew she
knew what she was trying to say she just
didn't know how to say it
yeah they in her mind she's like you
black [ __ ] [ __ ] skipper get the juice
punk-ass daddy
I knew that you see you're saying I
could tell by our hand movements you
dummy guy all this guy she got you black
[ __ ] bits kisses I'm so mad wanna
punch her right in the throat it's my
damn baby though it's my daughter man
I'm so protective of my kids though I
really am I don't even like taking my
kids out there much no more not getting
arguments with the other kids
oh I think kids play too rough I do man
this boy got into it at Chuck E Cheese
it was it wasn't a fight of the
altercation we got into a little
altercation because my baby was in the
balls he was throwing the balls and my
daughter he he's throwing the balls hit
my daughter right in here Wow I'm doing
it so damn stupid she thought it was a
game she plan
see like daddy look I'll get man like
throw ball back I'm pissed off I look at
my son he's just looking at the city I
was mad at the way my family looked as a
unit like me we didn't look good as a
unit man like you
my daughter's she taking balls to the
face my son shaking his head and
slobbering I'm small we look like a
[ __ ] circus hat stop telling your
kids that they special
maybe they special to you but not to me
I don't play that [ __ ] every day before
my kids leave the school I get them at
the dorm like Lola's are check this out
soon as you leave this door nobody gives
a [ __ ] about you nobody in the whole
world gives a [ __ ] about you nobody
thinks you're cute nobody thinks she's
smart nobody gives a [ __ ] about your
opinion nobody on the whole earth
outside of this door gives a [ __ ] about
you
and even some of the people inside the
house a little on offense but I think
we're gonna be the first generation of
old people as soon as someone gets old
they complain about the new kids and all
these kids today look they're crazy it's
always at the new it used to be always
that the new generation was too deviant
these kids are out of control they're
crazy they're immoral look at what
they're doing in our day if we wanted
fun we just went to a barn dance and we
didn't even finger-fuck - we were like
35 years older but these kids today it
was always if the new generation was
over-the-top and we're gonna be the
first generation of elderly people
complaining but in the opposite fashion
where we're going look at these kids
today these have [ __ ] we we used to
do crank off a titty dancers and [ __ ]
we've got some good stories and herpes
out of the deal is
good the blisters bring me back these
[ __ ] they drink a Red Bull for some
pet and they prefer if you went on the
patio for a cigarette
the closest they come to a fistfight is
on a message board somewhere you look at
it my girl I'm gonna delete you from my
myspace friend got some block user in
your future [ __ ]
when you wear my girlfriend got pregnant
you know okay we need meat cup when you
haven't got a child couples who have
children are always bragging about how
cool it is to have children yeah
whenever you make couples with children
there was like it is the most fulfilling
thing I've ever done with my life my
heart grows larger and larger every day
and then the second that my girlfriend
got pregnant those same people went like
this
you're never gonna sleep again forget
about it it's over you're not gonna
sleep there cuz they telling you you're
not gonna sleep okay raising a baby's
not that hard I'll tell you what it's
easier than a coke habit I had a coke
habit for seven and a half [ __ ] years
at least it's not me who wakes up crying
anymore I can sleep through other people
cry I've had girlfriends it's like white
noise to me I find it soothing
[Applause]
now when they start thinking they know
stuff bunches I don't you know my
buddy's got a kid his kid is at that age
right
they invited me over to you know come to
dinner the other day because I'm like at
that age I'm like that weirdo guy they
feel they feel sad for so they gotta
fight me over yeah I really have a
pathetic existence it's quite my life so
I'm sitting I'm trying to be social with
the kid you know he's really into space
so I'm like hey look the skies around
and the stars are out the kids like
actually that's not a star dan what is
joking her joke better is the fifth
planet that [ __ ] like you're
impressed that's amazing Wow really is
it is it they won't shut up they just
keep going on it's good 17 moods and I
gotta sit there acting impressed cuz I'm
just waiting for another adult to come
by and just scoop the kid up and just
rescue me got a sinner react like I'm
amazed with this I saw a stripper quit
on stage two months ago what do you
think you're gonna tell me that's gonna
blow my mind nothing so the kitchens
kept going on and on it's go dude go
dude
I couldn't take it anymore sooner I
finally did I just I afford a little
water
oh we didn't know what to do is break
because sandy just froze up peter knapp
the deeding at this social maturity to
be like dude is you just looking for one
sit down I am laughing my ass off
I'm dying I'm like I cracked the code I
finally figured out what to do in this
situation and you know what this little
bastards anyway in the kitchen he
[ __ ] told on me
then like buddy's wife comes running out
she starts screaming at me like I'm 5
years old which technically I am because
I'm pouring water unlike you know
six-year-old right you don't do that we
don't do that in this house Anderson no
no no not we don't do that I so my
temper came up and oh yeah you know what
[ __ ] you [ __ ] kids [ __ ] to put our
I'm out of here I don't need this right
I like kids
yeah I like some kids you can't like all
kids because some kids are shitty it's
true and some people don't want to ever
admit that there's people that are like
every child is like a star in the
shining sea no some kids suck man some
kids are just shitty it's true you've
seen him you know when you're in a story
you see you kid and you're just like
[ __ ] that kid manic is a [ __ ] jerk I
hate that kid shitty little kid man I
saw a kid like that once I was in a
store and I'm looking at this kid just
[ __ ] hating them cuz I'm I'm waiting
in line what am I gonna you know that's
what you do when you're waiting in line
is do you just pick someone to hate
while you're waiting you know just some
guy you just start forming an opinion
with no information at all [ __ ] loser
hey girl I'm gonna crap wearing a tie
you what do you think you're better than
me you know just
just to occupy yourself he's standing
there he has no idea you're boiling with
hatred you know so I picked this kid and
I'm hating him he's shitty he was like
just seem like a shitty kid to me and
I'm looking at him and then he looked at
me and the worst thing is that this is a
true story this kids look at him he's
like six years old nobody else was
looking so I just want like this woman I
just flip them off
just real quick little thing between me
and him and he couldn't believe it he's
like oh he was blown away
cuz nobody does that nobody gives the
finger to some kid for no reason I think
I help them out a little there you know
yeah that happens deal with it yeah I
think parents must want to do that to
their kids all the time as much as you
love your kid that has to be those times
your kids be in this [ __ ] he's going why
can't I have a candy I wanted it campy
and you just want to go hey you know
what [ __ ] you kid alright yeah [ __ ] you
you like that huh
[Applause]